As I get older it seems my well meaning aunts
always ask, WHEN ARE YOU GONNA HAVE A BABY?
You’re not gonna be young forever!
Well Aunt Gayle, I might not be young forever
but there is a way I could keep my eggs young
for quite some time.
Hey everyone Julia here for DNews
Over 30 years ago doctors successfully grew
an embryo from a frozen egg.
Back then it was considered experimental and
used for women who might undergo chemotherapy
or other medical procedures that might harm
their eggs.
These women could freeze their eggs and use
them at a later date.
Now it seems to be all the rage.
Women delay pregnancy for all sorts of reasons,
like focusing on school or career or waiting
to settle down with someone.
But they still worry about fertility, so now
the egg freezing trend is taking off.
One egg freezing company hosted a cocktail
party in New York to advertize their business,
and big tech companies like Apple gives its
employees up to 20,000 dollars towards egg
freezing as a health benefit.
While it’s growing more common, it’s still
really expensive.
It can take about $10,000 just to freeze your
eggs, then a few hundred bucks a year to store
them and a couple more thousand to thaw them
and undergo in vitro fertilization treatments.
So it still remains a treatment for the wealthy.
But besides the cost it’s a pretty intensive
process.
It’s not like they just pluck out your eggs
and put them in a freezer.
Nope.
You have to take hormones for a few weeks
to stimulate the ovaries to release a few
eggs.
Which can leave you feeling bloated and a
little off.
You get regular check ups to see how the eggs
are coming along, then the procedure to remove
the eggs sounds not all that nice.
It’s kind of like drawing blood.
A needle has to pierce your vaginal wall and
reach the ovarian follicles and retrieve the
egg.
Okay Ouch.
Once the eggs are removed they’re cooled
to sub zero temps and stored.
But the freezing process does a bit of damage.
It makes the shells harden, which can make
fertilization tricky.
But using a technique similar to IVF, sperm
can be directly inserted into an egg, bypassing
the hardened shell.
But since this whole thing is kind of new,
no one really knows how long eggs are good
for.
Although, one clinic successfully used seven
year old eggs.
The procedure can’t boast a high success
rate.
According to the American Society for Reproductive
medicine one egg has a 2-12% chance that it
will develop into a fetus.
So doctors recommend freezing a few eggs,
some women freeze a dozen or so for later
use.
So with all the high cost and low chances,
why do people do it?
Freezing your eggs is a kind of pause on fertility.
Women are born with all the eggs they’ll
ever have.
They don’t produce them throughout their
lives like men produce sperm.
So you use ‘em or you lose ‘em.
According to the American Society for Reproductive
medicine, women are most fertile in their
20s.
Fertility declines gradually through the twenties
and thirties, but the decline picks up speed
as women enter their late thirties.
As a woman ages she loses eggs through ovulation
or through a process called Atresia which
is the gradual loss of egg containing follicles.
Even the eggs that remain degrade over time
and the risk of birth defects increases.
By the time a woman is in her 40s only 10%
of her eggs are good and the chance of successfully
fertilization drops to below 5%.
With chances this low, it’s no wonder women
hedge their bets by freezing their younger,
healthier eggs.
While this might seem like a ladies only issue,
gentlemen, you shouldn’t wait to have kids
either!
Check out this video here to find out why.
Would you ever freeze your eggs?
Or do you have another science question?
We’ll save some of your best questions to
answer in future videos.
So like this video and subscribe to our channel
so you don’t miss your answer.
and as always, thanks for watching.